hey guys it's Peter Brown standing in
for freelance reviewer Heidi camps as
the current Naruto manga and anime come
to a close so too does the ultimate
ninja storm game series like its
predecessors ultimate ninja storm 4
features a large roster of characters
from the sprawling saga and offers
stylish battles and free roaming arenas
but for the first time you can assemble
a team of three characters and swap
between them as you bet although they do
share one lifeline ultimate ninja storm
4 is by no means a balanced fighting
game one with layers of esoteric systems
to master but it does have characters
that are simple to control that have
impressive abilities at their disposal
it's easy to become infatuated with the
game's flashy and entertaining battles
for what they are you constantly zip to
and fro while throwing projectiles
executing attack combos and escaping
from danger you can teleport away from
your opponent and attempt a
counter-attack whenever you're under
duress the going gets really tough you
can use items that recover health grant
power boosts or cause massive explosions
since every character has the same basic
control scheme you don't need to worry
about memorizing character specific
command lists ultimate ninja storm 4
isn't well suited for highly competitive
players but it's a great experience for
people who want to experience what it's
like to be a cartoon martial artist with
access to absurdly powerful and
entertaining abilities
developers cyberconnect2 s Naruto games
always receive a great deal of praise
for their visuals an ultimate ninja
storm 4 is no different in this regard
the cel shading on the characters makes
them look almost indistinguishable from
the representation in the anime and
little visual details like armor and
weapons shattering or close
deteriorating from fire elevate the
impressive artwork to new heights when
the game showcases its characters and
elaborately choreographed cutscenes the
visual splendor is even more captivating
but sadly there are less of these scenes
than in the previous Ultimate Ninja
Storm games as some are now presented as
still images instead Ultimate Ninja
Storm 4 is story mode recounts the later
chapters of the Naruto saga taking you
through a chain of interconnected events
and battles from different characters
point of view unfortunately due to its
place in the series timeline anyone who
hasn't followed the show or the manga
will undoubtedly be lost there's also an
adventure mode that offers a series of
fetch quests where your ultimate goal is
to foster a relationship between Naruto
and his blushing bride-to-be Hinata
these quests are definitely basic in
nature but for Naruto fans they're
enjoyable opportunities to wander
through numerous locales from the world
and interact with characters in ways
other than combat but once again the
allure will be lost on anyone who isn't
already a fan of the series rewards that
you earn from the story and adventure
modes can be used to purchase cosmetic
items for characters in your online
profile if you want to get everything
and there's a lot of stuff to get
prepared to spend a lot of time trying
to attain highest ranks and battles and
making sure you satisfy various bonus
conditions of each fight there are the
usual single-player and 2 player free
battles along with online combat free
battle has numerous variations Survival
tournament League and a training focused
practice mode online mode offers limited
time single-player events and rewards
along with online matchmaking oddly
though the online mode in Ultimate Ninja
Storm 4 is missing features from past
games there's no longer a spectator mode
and lobbies are limited to four players
half of what ultimate ninja storm 3
supporting the attention to detail and
ultimate ninja storm 4 will no doubt
please existing fans of Naruto but the
things that group loves may very well
fly over the heads of the
initiated however beneath the fanservice
lies an accessible and entertaining
fighting game that looks great with some
of the best cell shading rendering
around ultimate into storm four can be
enjoyed on a superficial level by all
but it's clearly built for hardcore fans
of the series
you